[Music]  Real Housewives of New York star LuAnn  de Lesseps is now LuAnn D'Agostino she  and Tom have tied the knot it's a big  celebration New Year's you receive it's  our wedding in itself birthdays  yes LuAnn and her fiance of just about a  year said I do in Palm Beach Florida on  New Year's Eve which also happens to be  Tom's birthday there's a kind of a vibe  or a theme for the big day you know what  is threefold  so it's Tom's birthday is gonna be 15  it's our wedding and it's New Years Eve  so I felt I feel like I should change it  up so I'm gonna do three different  dresses why not my big night why not  have a lot of dresses reality star  gushed to et about the big day a few  times in 2016 it's a very exciting time  I mean you know this is the most  exciting time of my life  getting married again after all this  time you know I'm thrilled and so I'm  not going to let what's happened on the  show were in the most exciting time in  my life  you